We have ourselves today one of those stories
that sounds completely believable based on
everything we know is being widely reported
by multiple sources and is being called completely
false by the Trump administration.
Now, I want to be really clear.
I'm going to tell you what's being asserted.
I do not believe that this is actually going
to happen.
OK, so let let me tell you that up front.
But ultimately, the story does come down to
who do you believe?
A Republican Party operative told Fox News
that Donald Trump is number one in an extremely
fragile state.
That's the word that was used.
Fragile state and that he may drop out of
the 2020 presidential race if Trump doesn't
believe that he has a shot at being reelected
president of the United States.
Now, there's a lot to discuss here.
Publicly, Donald Trump has been saying he
doesn't even believe the polls that show him
losing to Joe Biden.
That's what Trump has been saying publicly,
privately.
We keep hearing more and more that suggests
Trump does believe it, getting on the phone
with his campaign manager, Brad Parr, scale
and yelling at him and saying, how the hell
am I losing to Joe Biden?
He may have used a different word than how.
Now new reports that Donald Trump privately
knows that he is losing.
One person who's talking about this is Fox
business reporter Charlie Gasparino.
Now, you know.
I know Fox Business.
Gimme a break.
Charlie Gasparino.
I actually know a bit about Charlie Gasparino
is journalistic past.
He's been interviewed in a number of good
documentaries I've seen.
Charlie Gasparino is not the type of guy to
just make stuff up.
And I don't believe he would make this up.
And he posted in a series of tweets, quote,
Republican operatives are for the first time
raising the possibility that Trump could drop
out of the race if his poll numbers don't
rebound over the weekend.
I spoke to a sample of major players.
One described Trump's current psyche as fragile.
I'm not convinced yet, says Charlie Gasparino.
He's got time and he's running against an
opponent who is literally hiding in his basement.
Plus, the public isn't focusing yet on just
how left wing Joe Biden has become so much
so he can bring himself to denounce writing.
I think he believes he can't.
That said, the speculation indicates how tense
Republican operatives are about Trump losing
and the party losing the Senate and having
their entire agenda abolished in a leftist
wave election again.
Lots of time.
And Trump has endured a horrible couple of
months, but that's the snapshot.
A second source also says that they've heard
the talk about Trump dropping out.
But they don't believe it is true.
Now, publicly, Trump insists the polls that
have him losing are fake, phony polls.
On average, Trump is losing by nine to Joe
Biden.
But he tweeted, for example, yesterday, sorry
to inform the do nothing Democrats, but I
am getting very good internal polling numbers,
just like 2016.
The New York Times polls are fake.
The Fox News polls are a joke.
Do you think they will apologize to me and
their subscribers again when I win?
People want Law Order safety.
So the claim is privately, Trump is behaving
very differently.
He is fragile.
He believes the polls and he might even drop
out.
So that's the story as it's been precent presented.
Now, here's what I think.
I don't think it's going to happen.
I don't believe Donald Trump is dropping out.
Look at how Trump has been going after Twitter.
Twitter is terrible.
Twitter is horrible.
Twitter is biased.
Well, why not stop tweeting?
No. Trump is tweeting more than ever in the
same way.
I think that what's going on is that, yes,
Trump is fragile right now.
Yes, there are people around Trump telling
him that he really is losing.
And on top of that, there are Republican operatives
who want Donald Trump to drop out.
So I believe that what's going on is that
there are Republicans who recognize this is
bigger than Trump.
If Trump stays in and loses badly, which he
might or he might not, we might lose the Senate.
We could lose more seats in the House, we
could lose governors races.
And they are seeing that if that happens,
you could have a decade of a significant push
to the left that would undo a lot of the judicial
victories that the Trump administration has
had, thanks to Mitch McConnell.
It could undo a lot of the things that Donald
Trump has started to do.
So Trump focuses on no one but himself.
There is a world in which if Trump was genuinely
convinced, I have no chance to win in November,
that he drops out.
I'm not denying that Trump is not going to
be convinced that he has no chance to win
in November.
And thus, I don't think there's any chance
that Trump is dropping out.
I think what you are seeing here is sort of
a rumor management by Republicans trying to
put the idea in Trump's head that he's thinking
of dropping out so that maybe he will actually
do it to maybe help the Republican Party.
Bigger picture.
I don't think he's.
Going to do it.
Let me know if you have a different take.
I think this is Republicans pushing the idea
onto Donald Trump.
Remember that I am now bookable on Cameo Cameo
dot com slash David Pakman Forge's.
Just search my name in the app.
We'll take a quick break and be back after
this.
We're going to talk about Republican Congressman
Dan Crenshaw in just a couple
of minutes.
The David Pakman Show.
David Pakman.
Com.